entre l'hôpital de saint jérôme et
l'ukraine il y à des milliers de
kilomètres mais les horreurs de la
guerre résonne fort dans le coeur du
médecin julien augé moi je avec le fait
de rester assis les bras croisés
hanté par les images du conflit est
inspiré par le courage des ukrainiens dr
auger a pris sa décision il va bientôt
tentés de se rendre dans le pays ou leur
prêter main forte il répond à l'appel du
gouvernement ukrainien qui a besoin de
renfort dans ces hôpitaux pour soigner
civils et combattants pour ce père de
deux enfants quitter le québec est une
décision déchirante
c'est sûr qu'elle annonce à ma famille
c'est pas
c'est pas quelque chose qui fait plaisir
au niveau de savoir que je peux salle et
le piètre est en danger mais en même
temps je me sens tellement interpellé
tu es au plus profond de moi
certains veulent soigner et d'autres
sont prêts à combattre question
les roquettes russe tue des innocents
c'est de la folie 10e manitoba d'origine
ukrainienne il songe à vendre sa maison
et veut amasser le plus d'argent
possible avant de partir à ses yeux sa
place est sur le champ de bataille
ici je ne peux rien faire dit il
appel au ralliement du président
ukrainien trouvent écho chez les
occidentaux mais arrivé au zone de
guerre malgré paris est très risqué
souligne cet expert ça va être ensuite
la barrière de la langue est l
apprentissage express du maniement des
armes des pays comme le royaume uni
l'australie ont clairement tenté de
dissuader leurs citoyens de voyager pour
prendre les armes en ukraine le
gouvernement trudeau pour sa part il
perd son avertissement on était très
clair à avant la guerre que la situation
en ukraine est vraiment très très
dangereux mais métier qu'il s'agit d'une
décision personnelle
un pays dans lequel on respecte les
choix personnels ottawa a surtout le
devoir de bien expliquer les dangers
croit l'opposition s'ils y vont ils y
vont en sachant pertinemment que
personne ne pourra les sortir de là
advenant que la situation dégénère en ce
gouvernement canadien à l'instance
habilitée le démontrer les risques
impliqués dr auger lui espère que son
geste de solidarité va en inspirer
d'autres ça dépasse les limites de
l'ukraine c'est ça concerne tout le
monde je pense que dans le monde
démocratique le si on veut protéger
l'ordre mondial qu'on connaît depuis la
deuxième guerre mondiale je pense
pourquoi conseil plaide plus pour lui
cette cause l'on porte sur sa propre
sécurité ici louis blouin radio canada
ottawa